even though i can't make things
magically better with us
i'm just here to be supportive and i
just want her to be happy
kris jenner and caitlyn jenner just took
a major step towards repairing their
relationship
at least professionally the former
couple has been estranged
following caitlyn's transition and 2015
tell-all vanity fair interview
i don't think that i realized how
deeply the vanity fair article coming
out
would affect me it's just too much
but on thursday's episode of keeping up
with the kardashians
the two were able to make some progress
thanks to caitlyn's friend
sophia hutchins reaching out to chris
for professional guidance i can't
believe
chris is on the phone with caitlyn and
just
almost like nothing has ever changed
like her manager hat's right back
on i mean i think it's a huge step
forward for their relationship i mean
you know there was a time that they
weren't even talking no less helping and
dealing with work stuff
and i'm also curious if they're going to
be able to have a working stable normal
like working relationship again and
while chris's daughters
kim and khloe kardashian also questioned
their mom's ability to move forward with
caitlyn
they were happy to see her coming away
from the whole interaction with a
positive attitude
i'm just like proud of my mom for
reaching this place of growth where she
can
you know be super cordial with caitlyn
and just
put you know maybe if it's just baby
steps maybe you shouldn't put the whole
thing aside but like she's able to
communicate
and start that little relationship
building
as for chris she had this to say after
caitlyn took her advice
and posted her first cooking with
caitlin video on youtube
i just want to be able to help somebody
if they're hurting or in any way
need just some inspiration
and it's coming from my heart instead of
somebody telling me to do it
you know you just want somebody to
succeed and she
really does have a lot to say even
though i can't make things magically
better with us
i'm just here to be supportive and i
just want her to be happy
in march e.t was first to learn that
caitlyn would be appearing on the 20th
and final season of the hit reality show
put it this way uh i am in the final
season um
yes i make my return i over the
many over 10 years i did the show i
really enjoyed doing the show
we went through a lot together um i
think i have probably some of the best
conversations with my kids
on camera i think it really brought the
family
much closer and last year the former
olympian opened up about how the show
has created strong communication within
the family
the show was
the best at keeping the family together
to dealing with issues i have to say
i had some of the best conversations
with my children on camera
it kind of forces you a lot of times as
a parent
you put it off oh i need to talk to
kylie about this or kendall or ken
you put it off it's uncomfortable not
with the show the show knows what's
going on
you're there you're in front of camera
and you're talking to your kids
i think that show brought this family so
much closer together but kaitlyn's big
return to the reality show wasn't the
only keeping up bombshell
this is insane in a preview for next
week's episode
scott disick talks marriage with his ex
kourtney kardashian
during a family dinner is there anybody
that thinks we
shouldn't get married that would be epic
marriage marriage i'm feeling ambushed
right now
and in another scene the paris scene
having a one-on-one convo where scott
lays it all out either we figure out
creating our own lives together or
separately
that's a lot of pressure to put on me i
love you
of course both scott and courtney have
moved on and are in new relationships
scott made things instagram official
with 19 year old
amelia hamlin in february while court
and travis barker went public with their
relationship in january
and according to a source have gotten
quote way more
serious in recent months so i guess
we'll all just have to wait and see how
it plays out
on this season tune in because you never
know what's going to happen